I'm coming off of the exit which is
always super [ __ ] busy now I'm on a
motorcycle some [ __ ] they didn't feel
like letting me through put my foot down
to get around them and the back of my
bike hit my foot and pushed it forward
and now I can't tell if I broke my ankle
if I just sprained it really bad so my
foot is getting better although it looks
worse oh oh my god it actually feels way
better so I notice there's a GoPro over
the archery target yesterday I'm
assuming you guys using those bows to
shoot out of the target maybe some of
you had to have struggles bills I don't
get my bow strung right baby
I'm assuming it's been filmed
touching another man's bow is like
touching a man's life so I had to take
an uber this morning because I twisted
my ankle on my motorcycle and I'm unable
to ride I put my phone down next to me
and I was like I won't forget it
and then I left it in there and he came
all the way back here to bring it back
to me
this way I can 5 stars for sure I
dropped indecent warning today yeah
that's pretty awesome he didn't have to
do that what a guy but he must know the
feeling of being disassociated with his
phone and like any mother wants to
reconnect with their child but I'm gonna
give him 5 stars right now Ren's
engineer he's supposed to be good at
this oh my god Jake what are you doing
you
around okay I can't watch I wear this
I'm really a Jake Jake have a moment of
your time
Frank come on I'm going to teach you
guys how to string a bow
stop it you're doing it wrong already
hook around the end of the spring on it
is facing up
thank you thanks to it right now get it
so that's a limb without the spring that
spent on this leg it's going behind now
keep that part up on your thigh and now
Jake just get reach or it's far to the
end of the Bozek in Randy no no no no
it's a phony FS right now has a slip
ring come on
didn't work like this last time you go
oh I saw how it works
what do you mean get your boot summit ho
boots boots should never touch the tip
of a boat
why'd you give up what's up I swear to
god what's up bull
are you sure you're both now Ren and
Jake hopefully no more of my bow on the
concrete against the wall those are
ladies we are ladies output oh yes Emily
we all certainly two of them treat them
as such
it was a bull's-eye button care bulls
eyelid you guys have a tournament going
an archery tournament it's going to
happen
yeah bring my elbow for that left word
very nice
don't ever say you try shooting two
arrows on my bow
it works what it is actually possible
all right Jake's like halfway redeemed
you'll reveal all your demon you haven't
hit a bull's-eye with this shot bullseye
redemption comes another day all in a
day's work
nice and smooth one of us